forse ragazzi molti di voi ameranno né
caduto il telefono ameranno gli animali
come me questo gioco infatti tratta di
coccole a cani qualità video ludica by
fa vj autoplay come si gioca
6 a un party in casa va bè fin qua non
conosci nessuno ho invitato gente a caso
non conosco nessuno però va bene però la
leggenda dice che un very good puffo
pupo non è della serie pupa mia fava
vuol dire cagnolino tenero si nasconde
davanti a parte nella casa
l'orologio scorre e non sai di cosa
parlare alla festa beh come sempre anche
io riuscirai a trovare il cucciolo al
party westwood e poi ci sono i comandi
mi piace la zampina per scorrere
fantastico ma play a pupo galleria ci
sono livelli ci sono diversi tipi di
cannes e alla madonna gta spostati e la
madre mica 52 tipi di cani hanno fatto
se riconoscete il vostro cane tra questi
scrivetelo nei commenti scrivete anche
il suo nome perché mi interessa lei è
finita la canzone quando ho cliccato su
blake e precisione
buongiorno allora questa è la mia festa
in casa non conosco nessuno salve questo
si sta divertendo un sacco qualche bel
iphone ha così si dialoga con la gente
bene non ho mai fatto prima
un giorno mi dite cosa salva e tu ti
stai divertendo un sacco vedo è super
chiaro quello che mi dite
sono sempre comunque testi più
comprensibili di quelli di young
signorino c'è un calo e ho sentito a ma
si può nascondere anche negli eau tipo
nel frigo ste cose è la domanda è ma chi
siete perché che ci fate in casa anche
perché tu sei blu ma qualcuno sa dire un
qualcosa di decente salve
dov'è il cane aiuto perché tu hai pelli
perché il grafica cia sto gioco dio mio
costamagna la pizza
tu sei ma marylin prima mi chiasso già
ubriaco cane dove sei cane dov'è il mio
56 secondi c'è ma io devo solo trovare
il cane non devo fare al tram sono
veramente ubriaco dove sto cane farlocco
ma perché siete blu
qual è il vostro problema ma quanto
grosso stack a eccolo
art ho sentito un art veniva da qua
dall'armadio e sei stato tu a fare art
chi è che fa arf arf patto grossa casa
cane ti ho sentito non mentire
noi che se qua stai facendo tu e sheeran
e qua qua dentro sento sento
eccolo ce l'ho fatta you get up up di 30
secondi cleo find the pack che ai 44 ama
quindi si accumulano i secondi ok
dovremmo avere un pò culetto perché no
per sé un sacco prima cazzeggiando e non
lo sapevo io che si dovevano sommare i
secondi ma che ne so porca a quanto
grossa sta casa qualcuno mi dia un cane
lanciatevi un cane ecco aiuto non sa tu
sei una gnocca vorrei rimorchiati ma non
ho tempo devo attraversare un cane dove
si abbaia zio arf arf è già eccolo
gibson mel gibson line del pop si ho
capito un attimo che sta diventando
veramente difficile via scafa un record
decente se riuscissi a trovare che bella
sostanza ma ogni tanto abbaia però non
capisco la dove dovrebbe arrivare ad ora
mai iniziati
eccolo questo è bellissimo ai cagato
nella ciotola wat capote ai cappotti
dove se l'anno scorso si trovava nel
maledetto cane abbaia zio dove sto
andando
eccolo qua c'è la cuccia porca vacca
qualcuno mi dica dove il cane ecco lo
sei tu
questo a mio zio regala uguale sempre
più difficile accarezzare i cani nel
mondo youbet apap daisy e fuori la
finestra questo aiuto come la raggiungo
questo e fuori la gara è uscito quanti
siete ma fuori da casa mia macchina i
gol a voi parquet ma chi li ha invitati
questo ancora che se magna avis vado a
prendere a napoli la pizza non quella
roba lì ad ostiano eccolo si stava
scaricando da solo suo cane gustarli
cioè io poi vi lamentate che non vi
porto contenuti di qualità mamma mia
ragazzi quali youtube riporta sta roba
quale guarda che fare youtube da una
questione di coraggio bisogna saper dire
alla gente guarda che io faccio dei
giochi che tu non ci metteresti mai
neanche la mano sopra da lì si vede uno
che si merita gli iscritti non quelli
che fanno ct a questi giochi qua detroit
3 truffata anch'io puoi anche cagarsi
sul suo letto tanto non è mio
quindi va bene 73 secondi o shea che non
mi è andato a sti cani per l'amor di
gesù finirai prima di mangiare la pizza
se noi fanno il dlc visto gioco dove il
tipo finisce di mangiare la pizza non so
ragazzi se vi ho puntualizzato ancora la
musica fantastica visto gioco ma io
posso fare qualcosa parte far finta di
parlare con la gente
marca ecco ma è un gatto questo è un
gatto non è un cane
ap con pupi intendi anche gatti ma si
mai pensavo che i pup fossero i cani o
la cacca anche kakà si cepu non voglio
sapere cosa stai facendo va in bagno non
lo voglio sapere
la casa più grossa d'europa rega
mammamia eccolo penelope bene da boara
non ho mai visto non è più azzeccato per
un cane ma fatemi sapremo e si chiamano
i vostri che ho bisogno di sapere come
si chiamò i vostri cani no perché
secondo me sti nomi che non hanno senso
di esistere il prossimo cane che vedo lo
chiamo pietro ecco lo guarda e sommelier
che sto tizio ma come come se ne intende
di vino
sei una canna o poi lo vedo o di qua
minchia questo e strafatto bravo zio
fammi indovinare bobby coco però quasi
legge che non è tanto difficile trovare
al cane ma bisogna solo indovinare i
nomi così possibilità su un milione di
nominarlo possiamo cane si chiama
charlie tutta la vita affidate smetti di
bere birra porca vacca
ecco niente charlie dimmi che sei
charlie zio cosa pirata
magari si of dogs che quella cosa che mi
fa ridere che c'è un tipo che gira per
casa così con la mano dove sto maledetto
cane
eccolo cioè questo gira con la mano così
per casa ater tra un cane lo accarezza a
caso tutto il tempo così quando filtri
vede ora ci sono le scale addirittura a
quindi adesso passare sia sopra che
sotto hanno aumentato la difficoltà
avete presente i giochi dove devi
indossare delle cuffie per sentire tipo
fort knight questi senti da dove
arrivano i nemici no a il dolby surround
io non ho le uso le cuffie per capire
dove da dove a buy al cane perché la
direzione la capisco grazie al rumore
della baia 10 secondi la gancia for my
l'occhio accarezzo afghane che tu sei
abbastanza cagna spero no non lo è
a youdem perde papa è stato difficile
youcat 13 pax ex gloria e 270 stanze in
talking to 28 pv a the party dopo di che
sei andato a casa e ai guardati cartoni
finché non ti si addormenta te un po la
storia della mia vita ha quindi non è
casa mia questa è casa di qualcuno
ebbene play again ragazzo abbastanza ci
proviamo e ci mettiamo dei competitive
vai
[Musica]
oggi sei mio dio ci sono cucci ovunque
per un cane solo ma vi rendete conto dei
problemi eccolo lì se prima che ci
arrivo 15 secondi figure arrivarci
all'ultimo secondo l'ultimo secondo lo
so io che ci arriva l'ultimo secondo me
lo sento
ecco dov'è dov'è dai ecco all'ultimo
secondo
ho fatto giacinta al grande giacinta 11
dyilo arriva a 14 novate regole si
ficcano 30 secondi figurati se button
record minchia giacinta va salvato porca
vacca un secondo di cane porco pietro
col pedigree non troverò mai figure
ormai troppi pochi secondi mancano però
è stata un'avventura incredibile che
veramente sono contento fiero di avermi
reso partecipi di questa avventura
esco vincitore orgoglioso madonna che si
possa credere
melli sui fornelli grande nelle ancora
un crono a pareggiare il vecchio record
ai pareggiare vecchio record
traineeships dai subito subito subito
veloce subitissimo cai l'acqua dietro
caccia ha consentito ora qua dietro lo
giuro cioè il dolby surround nelle
orecchie presti giochi l'ho comprato
apposta e cuffie eccolo dai madonna
ragazzi ori pareggiato il record tutte e
due le volte per un secondo incredibile
si parla il core nuovo si guarda con
nuovo nuovo record devo farti di farcela
zio mi deludere giuro non mi deludere ha
detto sgabuzzino
non mi devi deludere fra porca vacca ori
pareggiato perché non ci arriverò mai
impossibile porca vacca dove era sto
cane non riesco anche a vedere quando a
bahia che peccato però ci avevo creduto
dove eri non l'ho mica vista 13 stavolta
è stato un casino ma son riuscito a
rifare 13 fantastico tornare a casa e
guardare i cartoni per poi addormentarsi
credo che sia la soluzione migliore
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto spero
che avete imparato che l'importante alle
feste non è conversare non è vero e non
è fare niente di tutto questo
accarezzate il vostro migliore amico
quindi ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come il momento mi piace anche
ai social comuni non tanto nelle
scrizione iscrivetevi sono stata per
iscritti e noi ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]